core booknotes dorothee hermann author
of Helen Keller a life it's taught from
1998 lasts about an hour
Dorothy Herman the subject of your book
a life is Helen Keller who was she
Helen Keller was the world famous
deafblind writer and essayist and she
was a woman that I always found very
fascinating here was a woman who spent
almost her entire life from the time she
was nineteen months old in darkness and
in silence and yet she accomplished many
many amazing things she wrote many books
among them the famous the story of my
life which was her autobiography and she
graduated from Radcliffe College she was
the first deaf blonde person ever to
graduate from college and she was also
an advocate for the blind and the deaf
blind yet interestingly as famous as
Helen Hillier was I discovered as I was
beginning my research that many people
are only familiar with the early part of
her life and this was the part that
William Gibson portrayed so compellingly
in the miracle worker
and also ironically because Helen Keller
was so revered in her lifetime that I
found that many people had ceased to
regard her as a real person and that's
why I wrote my book to find the real
woman behind the myth when did she live
Helen Keller was born in 1880 and she
lived until 1968 and she lived in
incredible 88 years having this
condition and you say she was deaf and
blind could she speak at first no she
suffered at the age of 19 months a
disease that at that time was known or
as brain fever that's what the doctors
of the period diagnosed it as being to
this day we don't know what that disease
was whether it was scarlet fever which
was very prevalent at the time or
whether it was a spinal meningitis or
whether it was rubella but whatever this
disease was it completely wiped out her
hearing and her sight and as a result
she could not speak although there was
certainly nothing wrong with her vocal
chords now if you go out here to the
National Cathedral right here in
Washington you can find the ashes of
three people if I understand you
correctly in your book Helen Keller
Polly Thompson and Annie Sullivan why
are they all three buried there they had
first of all for them it was an honor
during their lifetime for them to be to
consider being buried there because of
their of their fame during her lifetime
I would say that Helen Keller and
Eleanor Roosevelt were the two most
famous women of their generation what
about Polly Thompson who was she and who
was Annie Sullivan Annie Sullivan of
course was Helen Keller's teacher she
was a very very young woman when she
went to Tuscumbia Alabama where Helen
was born it's in a rural part of Alabama
Annie Sullivan came from a background
that was really as horrendous as Helen
Keller
her parents were illiterate Irish
immigrants who came to Massachusetts
after the Great Famine and her mother
died of tuberculosis at a very young age
her brothers and sisters also died at
young ages and then her father abandoned
the family and Annie and her young
brother Jimmy were placed in an
almshouse in Massachusetts where Jimmy
subsequently died
and it was in a unique position to
understand Helen because she was half
blond herself and she suffered from a
viral disease of the eye then until 1937
with the advent of sulfur drugs was
responsible for much of the blindness in
the world
here's a picture in your book in the
later years of Helen Keller on the left
and Polly Thompson on the right now how
did Polly Thompson figure in this Polly
Thompson was Helens second companion
after the death of Annie Sullivan in
1936 and she was very loyal to Helen she
accompanied her on many of her travels
because Helen in her later years was a
fundraiser for the American Foundation
for the blind and she traveled worldwide
to raise public awareness of the needs
of the blind she was however not the
brilliant teacher and companion that
Annie Sullivan was - to Helen Keller she
did not have any Sullivans flair for
making the world stimulating this this
outside world that Helen Keller never
saw or heard so interesting to her but
she was she was certainly in terms of
just being loyal to her and devoted she
was certainly an excellent companion to
her how many books have been written
about Helen Keller I would say perhaps a
half a dozen but most of them I found in
preparation for my own book either
sentimentalized her life terribly so
that we did not work we ceased to regard
her as a real human being or else I
missed the drama of Helen Keller's life
because Helen Keller's later life was in
my mind more
dramatic than the early part that most
people are familiar with through the
miracle worker here was a woman who
became world famous shortly after the
the miracle mainly because of Alexander
Graham Bell who was very interested in
her Bell invented the telephone
partially as a hearing aid he had a deaf
mother and a deaf wife and he wanted to
use what had happened in Tuscon via the
so-called miracle at the well of Helen
understanding language to promote
awareness of the Deaf and his theories
of teaching them the other person who
certainly promoted Helen Keller was a
director of the Perkins school for the
blonde in Watertown Massachusetts which
by the way is the first school for the
blonde in the united states and he
pronounced Helen to be a prodigy so when
people heard about what had happened
it's escambia and then with the
influence of these two important men
especially Alexander Graham Bell Helen
was was world famous but then shortly
after that she sent a nag nose as a
matter of fact a little birthday gift
which was supposedly an original story
that she had written and he proclaimed
it here was a man who was I must say
given to exaggeration
I mean he's taught me to ask you who an
egg nose was he was the director of the
Perkins institution for the blind race
and Watertown Massachusetts and he
pronounced this story that was his
birthday gift as without a parallel in
the history of American literature
unfortunately for Helen Keller that
story was a plagiarism it was
plagiarized from one of Margaret Candy's
children's stories and Margaret can be
was the famous
children's book author of the period and
after that I mean people then began to
suspect Helen Keller of being a fraud
and you're talking about and it pops up
more than once in the book the title of
the cheer up was what she wrote was
called a frost King the frost king yes
and Helen Keller wrote the frost King in
what year in what year that I'm not sure
I would say probably around 1896 and how
long was it before that people thought
it was a fraud that she had plagiarized
almost immediately and she therefore
became suspect in many people's eyes of
course as a as a biographer this was one
of the my great challenges is just in
discussing her relationship with Annie
Sullivan and that was namely who was
doing what in this relationship was
Helen Keller really a genius and through
which and Annie was her instrument for
expressing that genius or was Annie
Sullivan the genius and Helen Keller her
mindless puppet and certainly after the
the frost King incident there were many
people who accused her of being an
Sullivan's puppet and that she was
mindless and sullen if Helen Keller to
1968 and Sullivan lived to what year
till 36 1936 and then Polly Thompson
died what year she died in the late in
the late 50s you got interested in all
this how in the first place I always
found her to be intriguing as I said
before the where though where were you
yeah first time you remember saying I
want to do a biography on Helen Keller
where did you live and what were you
doing I was living as I am now in Bucks
County Pennsylvania I had just finished
up
biography of Anne Morrow Lindbergh who
lived in nearby Hopewell New Jersey and
mrs. Lindbergh's life was certainly very
dramatic and after I finished that
biography I wanted to do a biography of
another person who of that generation
another woman another woman who was
considered a heroic and inspirational
figure of the 40s and 50s and naturally
Helen Keller came to mind why did you
want to do another woman I think that
having done a male subject my first
biography was about s J Carroll Minh and
I found that after doing his biography
that I I wanted to do a female subject
and found in doing mrs. Lindbergh's work
that that I felt more at home that I
could understand the psychology better
of a woman then I could of a man of
course it was SJ Perlman's
very complicated psychology that I was
dealing with and I don't know if I can I
can really compare any of my subjects
because they've all been so so different
but I do look for somebody who does have
a dramatic life and Helen Keller
certainly certainly had one what year
did you start to Helen Keller research
about four years ago and when I first
began it I wondered whether I really
could attempt such a work as a hearing
sighted person but fortunately for me I
was introduced by the staff at the
Perkins school for the blonde in
Watertown to some amazing deafblind
people and I also lived for a week at
Perkins where
met many deafblind people and then I met
Robert Smith of the Helen Keller
National Center for deafblind youths and
adults in Sands Point New York and mr.
Smith is had lost his sight and hearing
at a later age than Helen Keller but I
found that after about three minutes
with him and he had known her by the way
so he had some very interesting
anecdotes to tell about her I found that
after about three minutes with him
I completely forgot that he was a
deafblind person how did he hear you
speak through an interpreter who knew
the manual finger language and then
because he was trained under a different
method than Helen Keller the Sodoma
method of speech which has since gone
out of favor among certain teachers of
the Deaf blonde and the deafblind
themselves he was able to answer me
directly in a very comprehensible
speaking voice how many I remember you a
figure in the book but I don't know how
for what period how many deafblind
people are there in either the United
States or in the world you had a figure
of 50 in the book for some period of
time is that we've ever known that 50
people in this country have been deaf
and blind it is estimated that 50 people
in the 20th century have completely lost
their sight and hearing at a very young
age this doesn't mean that there aren't
deafblind people but there are people
who may be deaf or hard-of-hearing and
then gradually lose their sight but not
this complete loss it's an extremely
rare disorder and fortunately we have
eradicated those diseases I mean we
don't no longer people do not get
scarlet fever so that the most of these
diseases have that causes type of
devastating handicap ax
have been eliminated now how did you get
interested in being a writer I came from
an artistic family my father was Bernard
Hermann who is the film composer and did
the music for Citizen Kane and many
Hitchcock films among them vertigo and
psycho my mother is a mystery and
suspense writer her name is Lucille
Fletcher
who wrote sorry wrong number and my
stepfather was a novelist and he wrote
the among other works the year the
Yankees lost the pennant which was made
into Damn Yankees so let's say I
inherited the fan I just wanted to grow
up being a writer because I was around
writers and I also had the false
impression since they didn't go to jobs
that this was an easy life that you
could just get up when you wanted to and
work for a couple of hours and that
would be yet of course later I was to
learn that the muse is a really tough
dollar where did you go to college I
went to Middlebury College in Vermont
and studied English there and to prepare
for this besides going to the Perkins
school did you do other thing did you
ever spend a day where you couldn't hear
or see did you try to do that I did at
the beginning I put on a blindfold and
put in earplugs and did all of that and
tried to figure out how far or how
easily I could get around my house and I
found that it was quite a feat to get
from the downstairs to the living room
upstairs
I at the beginning I thought about
perhaps really going into a floatation
tank or really centrally depriving
myself but I was warned against it by
people because they pointed out to me
and this was these were people who had
worked with the deaf blonde
and that for Helen Keller this was a
totally natural
condition and that one could never
duplicate it and it was true that for
her this was a really valid alternate
reality and that was one of the
surprises to me as I worked on the book
that I thought that she lived in a
silent black pit and that was far from
the case she had a very interesting
world that she lived him and it was
filled with vibrations with smells with
taste and of course when she she after
Annie Sullivan broke through to her in
the next few years she learned Braille
before Braille was standardized she
learned many other types of raised print
so she had a great deal of information
at her disposal how did she become a
socialist and how important was that to
the way she reviewed in this country to
talk about Helen Keller and socialism is
complicated and I'd like to backtrack a
little bit and talk about and Sullivan's
husband John Elbert may see and this may
come as a shock to many people who have
seen the miracle worker but Annie
Sullivan did get married and she married
a man by the name of John Macy who was
an instructor of English at Harvard who
was brilliant handsome
he helped Helen edit her 1903
autobiography the story of my life
he was much older than I mean actually
he was much younger than Annie Sullivan
and a doubt only a couple of years older
than Helen and they married when any
Sullivan was about 40 years old and
it had to be one of the strangest
marriages on record because one in this
picture is John Macy
he is the gentleman who is the second
from the right so he's in the middle
he's in the middle yes who's standing
who's standing that is Anne Sullivan
Macy and then the woman who is seated is
Helen Keller and the gentleman on my
right is John Hitz who was Alexander
Graham Bell's secretary and of course
they love dogs Helen and Annie did and
so that's one of their their dogs in the
middle so the relations between John
Macy and Annie Sullivan started where it
started at Radcliffe College Annie
Sullivan was having additional problems
with her eyesight and to get Helen
through college was quite an ordeal
because she had to literally spell
everything into her hand and it was very
it was a very difficult time for both
women and John Albert Macy as I said
before stepped in he learned the manual
finger language so is to be able to
communicate with Helen and he did help
her with her with her autobiography then
he and Annie Sullivan fell in love and
they were married a few years later she
was 40 he was about 28 years old and it
was said that he married in essence
really to women for years there's been
speculation about which a woman he was
really in love with what's this picture
again this picture is of a Helen Keller
and Annie Sullivan and he saw was
looking out at us yes and Helen is
resting her head on her chest
I think Helen by that time was about 18
and Annie Sullivan was 32 what was their
relationship all through the years they
were together do they live together oh
yes they they were never parted only
death parted them their relationship was
very complex it was a very strengthening
relationship I felt but it was also a
suffocating relationship I think that
both women even though their strange
bond meant that they couldn't uh could
not really lead independent lawns
because it was Annie Sullivan's devotion
to Helen that in the end wrecked her
marriage to John Macy but overall both
women would have been diminished without
this intense relationship I mean there's
never been another relationship like the
relationship of these two women in
history or literature and Mark Twain
they're their good friend didn't even
consider them two separate things he
said it takes the two of you to make a
perfect whole but surely that people
people have asked me what would have
happened to Helen Keller without any
Sullivan and my own feeling is is that
she would have been institutionalized or
she would have been kept in some lonely
shuttered back room in Alabama and then
Annie Sullivan would not have enjoyed
the world fame that she did as Helen
Keller's companion and teacher this is
the picture on the back of the book you
know where this was taken and what their
ages were then I don't know where this
intriguing photograph was taken it's in
the Library of Congress as a collection
the Bell collection and when I saw it it
just took my breath away because you
really that the photographer really
captures the essence of these two
women of Annie Sullivan bringing this
woman out of the shadows which is what
she she did and what she dedicated her
life to doing socialism John Macy's yes
let's connect to him John Macy was a
socialist quite a violent socialist and
he wrote a book called socialism in
America he was a ranted and raved
against the capitalists of the time and
I think that it is debatable whether
Helen Keller would have become such a
rabid socialist had she not met John
Macy he was a tremendous influence on
her and uh but once she was exposed to
socialism it was something that she
believed in her entire life
she eventually did tone down her
speeches and also her writings about
socialism because among other things she
was a very practical woman
she had to earn a living and there was a
time when for her to have been such an
outspoken advocate of socialism would
have gotten her into a great deal of
trouble and she was smart enough to know
that where besides Tuscumbia Alabama did
Helen Keller to live in her life she
lived for many years in the Boston area
she had she and John Macy
and Annie Sullivan shared a home in
ratham Massachusetts and then she lived
in Connecticut after Annie Sullivan's
death she lived near the Westport area
and had a large and very comfortable
house that she shared with Polly
Thompson
but then in 1946 there was a fire that
devastated her home and many key papers
were lost we're not exactly sure what
those papers were even people who were
extremely close to Helen Keller have no
idea of what precisely was in that house
but it can be assumed that Ann
Sullivan's correspondence to her husband
was destroyed in that fire as was Helen
Keller's correspondence with a man named
Peter Fagan who was the love of her life
was the draft of the book teacher also
burned in that yes and teacher was the
name that she used for her teacher any
Sonny Sullivan uh and then I remember
writing that she had she took another
seven years to write that book
yes she did to write it write it from
scratch again she had to write it from
from scratch and it was very they're
difficult for her to write that book
that was long after teachers death and
uh she prefer Helen it was an incredibly
emotional experience people who knew her
well said that she was not an emotional
person
but when it was time for her to write
teacher and all during the writing of it
she developed all kinds of psychosomatic
ailments then she she broke down and
cried frequently that was the the depth
of her feeling that still persisted
about this woman who really raised her
from the dead what year did she have her
eyes taken out and I believe false teeth
put in and and we started wearing a wig
well the the false teeth and the wig
came at the at the end of her life when
she was the very old woman her the
question of her
was and this no other biographer has
ever pointed out about Helen Keller and
her family also went through great
lengths to conceal it but she did have
artificial eyes and you can see if you
study some early photographs of her most
of her early photographs are
photographed in right profile what about
this cover shot you know when that was
taken that was taken about the time that
she was in Radcliffe but I can't tell
you the amount of work that I went to to
find a photograph that actually and I
wanted to put it on the cover then
actually revealed her blindness this was
an exception because many people
photographers included took great pains
to conceal it for the early part of her
life so she was always photographed in
right profile all those early
photographs of her that you will see in
this book are all taken from right
profile and there were very elaborate
explanations about why she was always
photographed in right profile someone
said that she had a large blemish on the
left side of her face that she wanted to
conceal and so it wasn't until the early
1900s when she had to appear on the
lecture stage and again here was a woman
who was world famous but she needed to
earn a living she needed to go out there
be in front of the public and tell her
story and at that time her oz4 were
removed for both cosmetic and for
medical reasons and replaced with glass
ones this pictures in 1946 I believe yes
that was just before the that's Helen
with one of her her beloved dogs and
that was taken just before her house
burned to the to the ground and so what
year did she actually have glass eyes
put in I would say around 1911 but again
I can't pinpoint the date because the
the closest I've come to really
documenting it is that at the Helen
Keller archives
the American Foundation for the blonde
in New York there is a bill to Annie
Sullivan from a German manufacturer of
glasses and that never been revealed
before your book no why did they did
they try to keep it quiet I think so and
I think also Helen's family I've been
told were disturbed by the notion that
she had artificial eyes is there anybody
living in her family at all yes she has
a number of relatives who are in Alabama
and I've met some of them and they are
were very charming and very helpful to
me up during the writing of this
biography and I'd also like to add that
if anyone is in that area of Alabama
that you can go to dis cumbia and see
Helens
childhood home which is open to the
public and that was another thing that
was a revelation to me was to travel
there and to see the place where the the
miracle had taken place and also to to
run my hands over this enormous water
oak that is in the front of the of IV
green which is the name of Helens
childhood home and that was one of
Helens favorite trees and it's a very
interesting tree so I encourage anybody
who goes there to to do the same and you
will learn a little bit more of what
Helens experience was like is this the
house yeah yes it is
that's that is either green and to my
right is the annex where Helen was was
born Oh to the right yeah and then right
below that is a famous picture or a
famous point in this story what is this
that is the famous a pump where Helen
Keller she reached her hand under it and
she felt the rush
water and for the first time realized
that it was that it had a name and that
she connected the Russian water was with
with the words of the feeling of the
Russian water with the word water you
say that Annie Sullivan how old was she
that day how old was Helen Helen was six
and a half and on that day Annie
Sullivan started with teaching her the
word water and went on to teach her 30
other words that day she she did that
day but the process had been going on
for some time before she made the
connection Helen was just beginning to
realize that these intriguing finger
actions that Annie Sullivan was making
on her hand that these might have a
meaning and she began to she began to
become dimly aware of their connection
with the outside world
but that was the first time that she was
able to make the connection in her book
the story of my life Helen gave the
impression which she later corrected in
other in another memoir that once she
had made this association that she
immediately grasped everything and that
was not the case that a first Annie
Sullivan taught her nouns then she
taught her adjectives then she dropped
in the verbs and it wasn't until many
months had passed that Helen was able to
ask the simplest type of question but
that was certainly certainly the
beginning did you look at any film of
her any documentaries to get an idea
what she really was like what she
sounded like yes I did I've heard
recordings of her voice Helen
appeared in two films one was a 1980 18
film
called deliverance which has to be one
of the craziest films ever made it's a
sort of a docudrama combined with
symbolist imagery and it's it's a
completely crazy film but it does
include some very rare footage of Helen
of Annie Sullivan of Helen believe it or
not taking a rod in a biplane and she
was a very adventuresome woman how would
she listen to music she her love of
music I think has been exaggerated
although there's some controversy over
this people who were the closest to her
felt that she really could only
distinguish a few compositions she of
course hated jazz hated the vibrations
of it and said whenever anybody ever
plays jazz I have a wild impulse to flee
but as for her knowing specific pieces a
great many specific pieces of music I
don't believe that she did it was
sculpture that was the art that she most
appreciated because sculpture is
palpable as well as visual and there
were famous sculptures and sculptors of
the period who would watch her touch
these famous works of art and they
realized that she felt things in them
that they had just never never seen
themselves how would she hear somebody
talk she would she would never hear
anyone talk I don't know but I mean
would she put her hand up on could she
put her hand on the lips and understand
what somebody was saying yes she was an
accomplished lip reader it was very
tiring for her to do this but she she
certainly did this in public and she
could tell a great deal from a person's
voice she could distinguish she said a
northern twang from a southern drawl
and she knew a great deal from
vibrations and also from her sense of
smell she could tell when a storm was
coming
did she ever marry she never married and
this was of course one of the tragedies
of her life she said once that if I
could see in here I would marry first of
all she had one very tragic love affair
and her family broke it up with it was
with this Peter Feigin who was her young
socialist secretary Helen was 36 years
old at the time and I'd like to point
out that she was an extremely beautiful
woman in her day people always talked
about Helens spirituality and how she
reminded them of some religious figure
but in truth this was a physically
gorgeous woman with a beautiful figure
she had long chestnut hair gorgeous legs
and but she was not her family
especially her mother did not want her
to marry but Helen managed to defy both
her her family and Annie Sullivan this
was a onetime
she really did turn against them and she
and Peter Feigin had a love affair and
then they were going to be married and
they went to the City Hall in Boston and
applied for a marriage license and mrs.
Keller Helen's mother got wind of it and
she told Helen that she could never see
this man again but Helen was not to be
stopped she and Peter Feigin devised
this very elaborate scheme where he
would kidnap her and then they would be
married by a friend
but this again the Keller family portage
this they're getting married and this
struck me as terribly sad that one night
when she was back into scum B Alabama
she was she went out on on the porch and
met with with Peter Feigin how she got
these messages to him nobody has ever
been able to figure out and her sister
and her husband woke up and they
realized that she was communicating with
him and they drove him off the property
with a shotgun and then sometime later
they woke up this several months
attached they heard a noise on the porch
and there was Helen with her bags packed
and she was waiting for him and he never
came and so then she really didn't have
any choice but to resume her very close
third lifestyle did you look at her FBI
file I did how did you get that through
the Freedom of Information Act and by
the way the the FBI have formed me and a
typewritten note that the FBI has never
had never conducted a formal
investigation of Helen Keller and I
think probably one of the reasons what
had to do with her handicap that I think
at the time that if the J Edgar Hoover
would have made a terrible mistake
I mean I think he knew it to have
documented anything against such such a
radiant person what did you find in it
that during the late 30s and 40s that
she supported a number of organizations
that were later assumed to be communist
front organizations but she would
there's no evidence that she was ever a
card-carrying communist did you remember
the Wobblies she was yes she supported
the Industrial Workers of the
of the world a militant singing union
she was so very violent in a lot of her
political opinions and supported
actually rather violent measures when
the fight for women's rights occurred
she supported believe there was a
British suffragists
named mrs. Pankhurst who had who wanted
women to smash windows and things like
that and Helen supported her
wholeheartedly interestingly though
Annie Sullivan did not support Helen in
these beliefs nor did her family I think
they were aghast at her radical as you
say that John Macy was the socialist and
Mary were Annie yeah how long were they
married they were married roughly 14
years do they divorce they never
divorced because Ann Sullivan Macy would
never grant John Macy a divorce and he
had they separated and then he formed a
relationship with a woman who was a
deaf-mute and they had an illegitimate
child and by this time John Macy was the
editor of the nation he succeeded Carl
Van Doren as the editor of that
publication I think he was editor from
1923 to 1924 and she would not divorce
him she said that she didn't want the
publicity but the truth was is that she
was still madly in love with him and she
wrote some very very heartfelt letters
about him and to him that I've read and
she was passionate about him and when he
left her it really broke her heart and
then when he died I think that that was
the beginning of
her own end and by that time her site
was failing she went completely blind at
the end of her life and here was this it
was a terrible spectacle too for people
to witness because here was a spirited
fiery woman and at the end she was
completely emaciated and just also also
the thing that was very difficult for
her is that she could not reconcile
herself to her her blindness and where
was Annie when she died Annie Annie was
in New York City and I believe that she
was in Forest Hills it's where they were
living at that's where they were they
were living and it was interesting for
me to just study these two women one of
whom had a complete disability almost
her entire life and faced it very
bravely and said that she never thought
about her limitations and then to read
Annie Sullivan's letters towards the end
of her life and to realize that she
could not reconcile herself to her
disability but that often happens that a
person who is born a certain way as far
that are adjusted to to a disability
than a person who acquires it later in
life here's a picture of Annie and Helen
from back in 1922 1924 where they were a
vaudeville act explain that of all the
roles that Helen Keller played in life a
handicapped whiz kid a lecturer a writer
an advocate for the blind in the
deafblind I think she enjoyed her
vaudeville career the most vaudeville of
course was quite a tasteless
entertainment
at the time that she was in it she was
supposed to be the inspirational act but
she was the the exception besides the
usual circus performers and jugglers
there were people that had been in
prison who had been pardoned because
they had lovely voices they were on the
vaudeville circuit there were there was
an acquitted murderer at the same time
that Helen performed who had led a very
bizarre double life as them as the
husband of a woman in one city and the
wife of a man and the other and Anne
Sullivan was very more defined by having
to go on the vaudeville stage and they
did this because they need desperately
needed the money their film which was
made in 1918 deliverance was a
box-office flop and they needed money
desperately
but Helen felt the opposite she loved
being around ordinary not ordinary
people but you enjoyed being around what
you call the people she called her
fellow citizens and she loved the rush
and the glare and the noise that she put
it of the vaudeville stage Iran for 20
minutes yes and then on page 226 you
have all these cues and aise questions
and answers who asked the questions and
who gave the answers during the
vaudeville performance the audience gave
the would ask the questions but of
course Annie and Helen anticipated it
what a number of those questions would
be so the answers were were rehearsed
and then when they were asked to Helen
Annie Sullivan would translate them
using the manual finger language and
then Helen Wood would answer in her
broken speech and Annie Sullivan would
translate her answered answer back to
the audience what are these questions I
mean I'll read one what is miss Keller's
age there is no age on the vaudeville
stage was the answer does miss Keller
think of marriage yes are you proposing
to me
were these actual questions and answers
she gave yes in many instances I don't
know how much ad libbing they did but
knowing them they were probably prepared
to think on their on their feet question
does talking tire you answer did you
ever hear of a woman who tired of
talking question do you close your eyes
when you sleep I guess I do but I never
stayed awake to see that's one of my
favorite that way what do you think of
President Harding I have a fellow
feeling for him he seems as blind as I
am who is your favorite hero in real
life Eugene V Debs he dared to do what
other men were afraid to do and what did
she mean by that
well he opposed the opposed America's
entry into World War one and Helen
totally agreed with him that was very
unpopular stand to take at that time but
he was one of her heroes question who
are the three greatest men of our time
Lenin Edison and Charlie Chaplin why did
she think that well I think Lenin
because of his because of communism and
because she certainly did and did
believe believe in it and who is the
other Edison and Charlie Chaplin Edison
because she knew him personally and he
was one of the many famous people of the
day with whom she was acquainted and
Charlie Chaplin because when she made
deliverance she was out in Hollywood in
1918 he was very kind to her and invited
and Sullivan and herself backstage and
she read his lips and they evidently had
a very charming exchange he showed her
several of his films one more what do
you think of Soviet Russia Soviet Russia
that's the answer Soviet Russia is the
first organized attempt of the workers
to establish an order of society in
which human life and happiness shall be
of first importance and not the
conservation of property for a
privileged class
she certainly believed that and she
supported the Russian Revolution and the
Bolsheviks ironically Helen Keller
though had to compromise throughout her
life there is this discrepancy about her
political beliefs if one studies them on
one hand she denounced many capitalists
and yet she also accepted money from
them throughout her life as did John
Macy when he was married to Anne
Sullivan Macy so one might say that
because Helen was unable really to
provide for herself because of her
disability she was forced to to accept
pensions from people like Andrew
Carnegie and this humiliated her on on
many levels but yet she couldn't she
couldn't do with with without that type
of help not only from Carnegie but from
john d rockefeller for more Twain and I
think that her her embrace of socialism
and communism was something that it drew
her because she would have liked to have
been in a position where she did not
have to accept these various funds from
from these people all through the book
their references about the sexual
responsible sexual relations between all
these people and you for instance and I
just want to go through the list worthy
Annie and Polly and Helen Keller
lesbians no there's absolutely no no
evidence of that and I have
by this time red I would say ten
thousand documents there's absolutely no
evidence to support the theory
were there any relationships like for
instance between Helen and John Macy and
I rode down on the list here sexual
activity with Alexander Graham Bell did
he ever relationship with any of these
people and they came out that all this
came up in there did you find any extra
sexual relations among any of these
people by the time you got your research
finished no as for the John Macy Helen
Keller relationship there is no
supporting evidence the correspondence
that exists and we have to keep in mind
that that's the fire that devastated
Helens house in Connecticut also
destroyed probably did destroyed though
that correspondence but the
correspondence that exists points to the
fact that this was more like a
brother-sister relationship and also
after John Macy left the household
Helen was extremely upset with him
anybody that would have she anybody that
would have come or hurt her teacher I
think would have been somebody that
Helen would have been would have upset
Helen greatly so it was as far as I'm
concerned it was a brother-sister
relationship here's a picture of her at
age I think 83 or so what were her last
year's like her last year's were sad she
suffered a stroke when she was about 80
then she developed a diabetic condition
and she lapsed into senility and so that
this was a it was a very slow
deterioration for her but she was you
know never
afraid of death and she wasn't afraid of
aging and she died a very peaceful death
she just drifted off in her in her sleep
said people who were close to her at the
time kind of started out this way why
did all three of them end up at the
National Cathedral and at what point in
their after they were dead did they find
their way to the National Cathedral here
in Washington to be buried Annie
Sullivan was the first person to die and
so she was cremated and then buried at
the National Cathedral and I believe
that she was the first woman to be
buried at the Cathedral then Polly
Thompson died in the 50s and she was
buried at the Cathedral and then Helen
Keller was dead in 1968 she was cremated
and then she was following the funeral
service which was at the National
Cathedral it was an enormous service
many deafblind people and blind people
with the god dogs attended her funeral
many dignitaries of the time and then
she was buried at the at the Cathedral
which by the way I found it to my
interest that here was the woman who had
led such a quiet life and if you if you
visit her her grave at the Cathedral you
find that it's filled with sound because
there are many school children who come
through to to see her grave what's your
next book my next book might be a memoir
about my family here is the current book
by Dorothea Armand called Helen Keller a
life we thank you very much for joining
us thank you so much it's my pleasure
what a famous family know that a lot
Dorothy Herman is author of Helen Keller
a life it's published by Knopf Ezzor
Random House dot-com / Knopf for more
information next week on encore
booknotes Pickett's charge in history
and memory